now you know it's bad for the democrats
when they've gotten the new york times
worried about how they're handling
education
now liberal columnist michelle goldberg
sees the signs flashing red going all
the way into 2022. it's what we've been
saying since april 2020 here on the
angle that democrats desperately need
schools to get back to normal
well public schools may finally be open
across the country but in many districts
things are far from normal
in fairfax county an unvaccinated
student she writes identified as a close
contact of someone who tests positive
for covid must quarantine for 14 days no
matter the results of the student's own
covent tests
and at some schools
students have been forbidden she writes
to talk during lunch
and then further from ms goldberg at her
own kids school students must be masked
even during outdoor recess
she goes on to cite a different school
problem in the michigan schools have
been forced to close because of staff
shortages
classrooms are doubled up and principles
are acting as substitutes as pools of
candidates dwindle
she writes this as a complicated problem
but it sums up it's up to the state's
democratic governor as well as the biden
administration to solve it wow
now since the early days of the pandemic
the angle tried to warn democrats that
locking down schools would
damage children and the economies in
states that refused to open up
now it was obvious to anyone except the
rankest of partisans
that life had essentially returned to
normal in states run by more
conservative governors so in florida
south dakota texas georgia tennessee
parents had kids in school
and they were learning last spring and
even last fall
yet the democrats running these other
states and the school boards that are
just dominated by teachers union
influence they simply didn't care
so they ignored warnings and pleas from
parents and from us from everybody
but beyond the closures and the mass
mandates parents also began to see the
garbage their kids were actually being
taught
the most depressing and racialized
sexualized course content taught by
generally activists who were
masquerading as educators
so moms and dads describe the situation
kind of as a one-two punch to the solar
plexus
but rather than getting knocked out
parents punched back
hence the victory in virginia and the
nail-biter in new jersey and parents
began organizing and even saw some gains
in school board races in places like
left lane in colorado
challengers forced liberal school board
members in colorado to spend big money
to defend their seats
still conservatives picked up seats in
colorado's douglas county mesa county
colorado springs and greeley it's not
bad
things went the other way with voters in
some of the more liberal areas
denver suburbs wayzata minnesota
and guilford connecticut just to make
num you know name a few
apparently those jurisdictions can't get
enough of the negative lectures on white
privilege and diversity equity inclusion
they want more of that
the decline in our public education
system tracks the other parts of the
country where the democrats have
dominated
so your average city public school in
baltimore
is going to be about as well run as the
baltimore city council runs the city of
baltimore ditto for chicago hartford
connecticut and la
and in sunrise park middle school in
minnesota
rather than raising the bar for students
they decided to remove standards
altogether
grades will not include behaviors
attitude tardiness to class whether the
assignment was turned on later on time
this is really increasing the rigor of
grades students are encouraged to retake
revise quizzes papers projects the other
thing that you probably notice is that
we're not using anything under 50
percent we want our students to know
that learning takes work
yeah teaching actually takes work too
and instead of adopting smart policies
what they're doing is just pandering to
the unions to the race radicals to the
gender benders
today we see where 40 years of neglect
and politicization has gotten us
and the new york times michelle goldberg
and every other liberal out there should
know that the reason schools haven't
gotten back to normal and they're doing
nonsense like that
is because the left doesn't want them to
go back to normal they don't want the
old standards
to them schools are nothing but
anti-american propaganda outlets that
they then use to separate children from
the racist sexist traditional views of
their parents
so teaching american history as many of
us learned it
is out of the question now
because remember most of us grew up
loving our country despite her flaws
the laugh needs an army of new recruits
and it's climate change and anti-racism
revolution
and the schools are their trusted source
and now they have their puppet in the
white house helping them too
biden's goal is to make things easier
for the teachers unions
kids and what's good for them about
999th on his priority list
now this was obvious early on in his
presidency when he backtracked on his
promise that a majority of schools would
be open for in-person learning by spring
his goal that he set is to have the
majority of schools so more than 50
percent open uh by day 100 uh of his
presidency and that means uh some
teaching in classrooms so at least one
day a week
one day a week that was so pathetic
the unions also of course got a huge
payout in biden's so-called american
rescue plan and american parents and
their kids in turn got ripped off
but the rip-off didn't begin with covid
and george floyd
the fact is conservatives have been
losing ground in education for decades
remember the attacks on great books
classes on western civilization in
general the anti-nuke protests on campus
in the 1980s and heck professors and
students remember had to take a mental
health day after trump won the
presidency
for those mourning the trump victory
colleges are offering comfort with
everything from hot chocolate to plato i
know that
speaking for myself as a gay man i was
very concerned about the outcome of the
election and what it might mean for my
own rights so i assumed that students
would be as well
so i sent an email saying if you don't
feel like you want to be there that's
fine let me know and most of the
students took me up on that offer
shocker students don't want to go to
class
but now parents are realizing that the
radicalization isn't starting in
colleges no it's starting long before
that
and over the past 18 months many now
parents are voting with their feet
choosing homeschooling parochial and
other religious schools
or they're just moving to a red state
where their rights are protected and
kids education
priorities are put first
and think about this insanity instead of
listening to the concerns of those who
are paying the bills
the school boards in the blue states
responded by limiting access
to things like school board meetings or
just canceling the meetings altogether
they kicked out and arrested dissenting
parents and then they urged the justice
department to investigate the parents as
potential terrorists
and the whole time they denied that
radical racial views are even being
taught in the schools at all
facts never get in the far left way
never and they always have the media to
cover for them
parents know it's been their kids are
being indoctrinated with critical race
theory in virginia and the democrats
wanted to deny it and so well it's not
in the corrections showed up because
they don't like that i mean just just to
be clear it's not it's not in the
curriculum
um in virginia just just
like me here let me just read you a few
things just in 2015 while terry
mcauliffe was governor the virginia
department of education promoting
incorporating a critical race theory
lens in education you can still find it
on the department of education's website
still there
in february 2019 a superintendent member
for the virginia department of education
promoting crucial race theory and the
idea of white fragility it's not it's
not
part of the course it's not part of the
curriculum i would like to move on with
you
senator senator please don't bombard me
with facts because my producer can't
talk quickly enough in my ear to give me
a comeback that was pathetic
now parents have always known that
teachers tended to be more liberal we
knew that but the unwritten compact was
always that politics would stay out of
the classroom
but now the school boards are brazenly
violating that understanding
and this gives license to educators and
officials to openly mock parents
if you're gonna call me out i'm gonna
you up
sorry that's just me
they want to pick on us because they
want their babysitters back we have the
meeting open to the public right now
uh-uh
that's what lori just said great
great and they know that the school
boards will almost always back them up
so here's my message to the school
boards and the democrats who've been
covering for them
now you can spend your time trying to
convince yourselves or us that it's not
technically crt that you're using
but you know darn well what you've done
the type of books on your syllabus the
language you use in class the literature
you aren't assigning to your students
and your attitude toward conservative
students and parents
you know it
so good for the times is michelle
goldberg for seeing the writing on the
wall on some of these issues
but for many people it's already too
late for the public schools
it's obvious that the type of education
most parents want and most kids need in
a competitive world
is not something they're willing to
provide
so the public schools will continue to
lose enrollment because the left will
never back down on using the schools to
push its ideology
nor will they force the teachers unions
to take measures that would allow the
schools to return to normal
that means parents you're going to have
to continue to vote with your feet and
your money and that's the angle hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else